Good morning, Sam, I'm on the road here,...
...I-95 in New York and yes, already very crowded.
I'm doing what tens of millions of people are going to be doing today,...
...behind the wheel and sitting right here, seeing a whole lot of that.
A lot of brake lights.
This morning, the infamous Thanksgiving travel rush could come to an abrupt halt...
...in one of the nation's hubs.
That thick fog in Chicago that's creating zero visibility...
...could cause chaos for the rest of the country.
Now take a look at this.
A 30-mile backup on a Massachusetts Turnpike last night,...
...spreads snarls on all major highways in the eastern part of the state.
The top 5 cities bracing for the worst traffic today:...
...New York, Washington DC, Chicago, San Francisco...
...and the most tangled roads, in Los Angeles,...
...with holiday road trips there predicted to take 33% longer than usual.